what is a logistic regression how is it
calculated and most importantly how are
the logistic regression results
interpreted that's what we will discuss
in this video let's start with the first
question what is a regression a
regression analysis is a method for
modeling relationships between variables
it makes it possible to inferior or
predict a variable based on one or more
other variables the variable we want to
infer or predict is called the dependent
variable or Criterion the variables we
use for prediction are called
independent variables or predictors
but what is the difference between a
linear regression and a logistic
regression
in a linear regression the dependent
variable is a metric variable for
example salary or electricity
consumption in a logistic regression the
dependent variable is a dichotomous
variable what is a dasharmus variable
dichotomous variables are variables with
only two values for example whether a
person buys or does not buy a particular
product or whether a disease is present
or not
so with the help of a logistic
regression we can determine what has an
influence on whether a certain disease
is present or not for example we could
study the influence of age gender and
smoking status on that particular
disease
in this case 0 stands for not deceased
and one for deceased and the probability
for the occurrence of the characteristic
one characteristic present is estimated
so our data set might look like this
here we have the independent variables
age gender smoke status and here the
dependent variable with 0 and 1.
we could now investigate what influenced
the independent variables have on the
disease if there is an influence then we
can predict How likely a person is to
have a certain disease
now of course the question arises why do
we need logistic regression in this case
why can't we just use linear regression
a quick recap in linear regression this
is our regression equation we have the
dependent variable the independent
variables and the regression
coefficients
however we now have a dependent variable
that is either 0 or 1. no matter which
value we have for the independent
variables only 0 or 1 results
a linear regression would now simply put
a straight line through the points we
can now see that in the case of linear
regression values between minus and plus
infinity can occur
however the goal of logistic regression
is to estimate the probability of
occurrence the value range for the
prediction should therefore be between 0
and 1. so we need a function that only
takes values between 0 and 1. and that
is exactly what the logistic function
does
no matter where we are on the x-axis
between minus and plus infinity only
values between 0 and 1 result and that
is exactly what we want
the equation for the logistic function
looks like this we have 1 divided by 1
plus e to the power of minus set
logistic regression now uses the
logistic function
for set the equation of the linear
regression is now simply used this gives
us this equation
thus the probability that the dependent
variable is 1 is given by this equation
for given values of the independent
variables
what does this look like for our example
in our example the probability of having
a certain disease is a function of age
gender and smoking status
now we need to determine the coefficient
so that our model best represents the
given data to solve this problem the
so-called maximum likelihood method is
used for this purpose there are good
numerical methods that can solve the
problem efficiently as statistics
program such as data tab therefore
calculates the coefficients B1 B2 to BK
and a but how do you interpret the
results of a logistic regression let's
take a look at this fictitious example
for this we first compute a logistic
regression for these data on datadab.net
if you like you can download the data
set for free and follow the steps in
parallel you can find a link in the
video description
we go to datadap.net and copy our own
data into this table I just already
loaded the data set from the link when
we copy our data in here the variables
show up down there
we want to calculate a logistic
regression so we just click on
regression depending on how our
dependent variable is scaled data tab
will calculate either a logistic or a
linear regression under the tab
regression
we choose disease as the dependent
variable and age gender and smoking
status as the independent variables
data that now calculates a logistic
regression for us now we can choose for
which category we want to build the
regression model
our data could also look like this that
there is not not diseased and deceased
but 0 and 1. then we would just need to
click here and enter the labels one is
deceased and zero is not deceased before
we go into detail about the different
results a little tip if you don't know
how to interpret the results you can
also just click on summary in words
logistic regression analysis was
performed to examine the influence of
age male and smoker on variable disease
to predict the value deceased logistic
regression analysis shows that the model
as a whole is significant and then come
the different independent variables for
example for smokers the coefficient of
the variable smoker is b equal to
1.34 which is positive this means that
if the value of the variable is smoker
the probability of the dependent
variable being deceased increases
however the p-value of
0.089 indicates that this influence is
not statistically significant the odds
ratio of 3.81 means that if the value is
smoker the probability that the
dependent variable is deceased increases
by 3.81 times but now in detail to the
results we will now go through all the
tables slowly and understandably let's
start at the top
the first thing that is displayed is the
results table in the results table you
can see that a total of 36 people were
examined with the help of the calculated
regression model 26 of 36 persons could
be correctly assigned that is
72.22 percent
then comes the classification table here
you can see how often the categories not
deceased and deceased were observed and
how often they were predicted in total
not deceased was observed 16 times of
these 16 individuals the regression
model correctly scored 11 as not
deceased and incorrectly scored five as
deceased of the 20 deceased individuals
five were incorrectly scored as not
deceased and 15 were correctly scored as
deceased to be noted for deciding
whether a person is deceased or not the
threshold of 50 is used if the
regression model estimates a value
greater than 50 percent this person is
assigned deceased otherwise not deceased
now comes the chi-square test here we
can read whether the model is
significant or not
two models are compared for this purpose
in one model all independent variables
are used and in the other model the
independent variables are not used now
we compare how good the prediction is
when the dependent variables are used
and how good it is when it dependent
variables are not used the chi-square
test now tells us if there is a
significant difference between these two
results
the null hypothesis is that both models
are the same if the p-value is less than
0.05 this null hypothesis is rejected in
our example the p-value is less than
0.05 and we assume that there is a
significant difference between the
models thus the model as a whole is
significant next comes the model summary
in this table we see on the one hand the
minus two log likelihood value and on
the other hand we are given different
coefficients of determination R square R
square is used to find out how well the
regression model explains the dependent
variable
in a linear regression the R square
indicates the proportion of the variance
that can be explained by the independent
variables the more variance can be
explained the better the regression
model however in the case of logistic
regression the meaning is different and
there are different ways to calculate
the R square unfortunately there's also
no agreement yet on which way is the
best way data that gives you the ask
where according to Cox and Snell
according to Nago kerokee and according
to McFadden
and now comes the most important table
the table with the model coefficients
the most important parameters are the
coefficient B the p-value and the odds
ratio we will now discuss all three
columns in the First Column we can read
the calculated coefficients from our
model we can insert this into the
regression equation if we insert the
coefficients we get the following
regression equation
0.04
0.87
1.34 minus 2.73
with this we can now calculate the
probability that the person is deceased
an example we want to know how likely a
person who is 55 years old female and
smoker is to be deceased we insert 55
for the age zero because the person is
female and one as the person is a smoker
this gives us
0.69 or 69 percent thus it is 69 likely
that a 55 year old female smoker is
deceased based on this prediction it
could now be decided whether to do
another extensive investigation as I
said the example is purely fictitious in
reality there would certainly be many
other and different independent
variables but now back to the table in
this column we can read whether their
coefficient is significantly different
from zero the following null hypothesis
is tested the coefficient is zero in the
population so if the value is smaller
than 0.05 the respective coefficient has
a significant influence in our example
we see that none of the coefficients
have a significant impact as all
p-values are greater than 0.05
in this column we can then read the odds
ratio
for example the odds ratio of
1.04 means that a one unit increase in a
variable age which means that the person
is one year older increases the
probability that the person is sick by
1.04 times
furthermore their receiver operating
characteristic Roc curve is very
interesting in logistic regression if
you want to know what the ROC curve is
and how to interpret it watch our video
on Roc curve thanks for watching and see
you next time